You know what, there's something about people
watching super violent movies that just changes
our little brains…
Guys, my common sense is tingling...
Hey cinephiles, Trace projecting out into
the Internet for DNews.
Movies are getting more violent, sexual, and
profane.
Studies show violence in movies has tripled
since the 1950s, and PG-13 movies contain
more gun violence than R-rated movies since
2009!
In fact, all movies have gotten more sexual,
and even G-Rated movies have gotten more violent.
Shoot-em-up movies are fun!
But can also be bad for us.
So, with R-Rated comic book movies hitting
the theaters: what is all this violence, profanity
and sex doing to our brains?
As technology has improved and storytelling
has evolved over the last 100 years, many
movies have become more realistic, but still
depict crazy outlandish situations.
Unfortunately for us, our brains haven’t
evolved that fast.
When your brain sucks in the latest action
film, we react as if it's really happening.
For example, filmmakers often use violence
to get the "good guys" to solve a problem.
This teaches us violence solves problems,
which isn't realistic.
And has implications in everyday life.
Linfield College found women who watched videos
showing relational violence and aggression
(like, pretty much all wives of wherever shows)
went on to instigate relational hostility.
A 15-year study in Developmental Psychology
found if kids watch violent television or
movies they display more violence later in
life.
And this is regardless of sex, social status,
intellectual capabilities, or parenting styles
and parental aggressiveness.
The caveat is, the kids have to identify with
the characters on screen and believe the violence
is realistic.
Which studies have shown is happening more
often because of our silly lizard brains.
And this goes the same for everyone!
A study in Prevention Science, found a positive
correlation connecting teens watching R-rated
films waged in "sensation seeking," behavior.
Sensation seekers are those who crave risky
behaviors -- like alcohol use.
Studies found that teens who wouldn't normally
perform risky-behaviors, like underage alcohol
consumption, would be more likely to do so
after watching a movie where such risky behaviors
were portrayed!
DAMN OUR SUSCEPTIBLE BRAINS!
Unsurprisingly, children who were exposed
to sexually explicit movies and TV would then
go on to have sex sooner, as well.
In fact, a study by the Children's Hospital
Boston found "for every hour the youngest
group of children [aged SIX to EIGHT] watched
adult-targeted content… their chances of
having sex during early adolescence increased
by 33 percent."
And these behavioral changes have echos inside
the brain.
According to Columbia University, fMRI scans
of people watching violent imagery show activity
in the right lateral orbitofrontal cortex
-- the area involved in reactive aggression,
and the supplementary motor cortex -- the
area involved in planning and imagining behaviors.
Essentially, people would visualize themselves
BEING violent, and the part of their brain
associated with violent reactions was ALSO
active.
And another study found as teens watched more
violent content, their connection between
violent behavior and emotion weakened.
All this might explain why people who watch
violence can go on to be more violent in their
own lives.
It seems to me, when we see a lot of violent
media, we begin to disconnect the emotional
reaction to risky sexual activity, alcohol
abuse or violence with ACTUALLY doing these
things.
Making us more likely to try them.
But we can fight it, and it helps to start
with kids.
One of the researchers recommended we simply
pay attention to movie ratings.
Children are more impressionable than adults
they should quote "should not be permitted
to see R-rated movies."
Also, if the violent person is a role-model,
their actions carry even more weight.
To fight that, says another lead researcher,
we should simply point out movies are works
of fiction.
Funnily enough, having a conversation about
it really can help.
There's a lot more going on with this than
you think!
Julia looks in how the brain reacts to your
favorite movies in
this video…
What IS your favorite movie?
Is it action packed?
Let's make a list.
I'm going on vacation soon and need something
to do.